REPORT AND ATTORNEY BARR, THAT
WILL BE HAPPENING NEXT WEEK AND
THEY WANT TO DISTRACT.
HANNITY: NO SHORTAGE OF
CORRUPTION IN THE SWAMP IN D.C.
BUT PERHAPS THE MOST SINGLE,
DISHONEST, UNETHICAL PERSON IN
OUR NATION'S CAPITAL MIGHT BE
THAT GUY, THE COMPROMISED
CORRUPT CONGENITAL LIAR, ADAM
SCHIFF PRESIDENT RECENTLY SCHIFF
PUBLISHED PHONE RECORDS FROM THE
PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEYS,
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER JOHN
SOLOMON, AND HIS REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUE, CONGRESSMAN DEVIN
NUNES.
THAT MEANS THE CORRUPT COWARDLY
COMPROMISED SCHIFF WAS SPYING ON
A MEMBER OF CONGRESS AND THE
PRESIDENT'S PERSONAL ATTORNEYS.
AS KIMBERLY POINTED OUT IN THE
"WALL STREET JOURNAL," MR.
SCHIFF HAS TRAMPLED LAW AN
RESPONSIBILITY.
IF NOTHING ELSE, SCHIFF CLAIMS
THE DISTINCTION OF BEING THE
FIRST CONGRESSMAN TO USE HIS
OFFICIAL POWERS TO SPY ON A
FELLOW MEMBER AND PUBLISHED THE
DETAILS.
CONGRESSMAN NUNES IS WEIGHING
HIS LEGAL OPTIONS, RIGHTFULLY SO
HERE WITH REACTION, FLORIDA
CONGRESSMAN MATT GATES, PAM,
I'LL GO TO YOU AND YOUR LEGAL
EXPERTISE.
>> HE GOT THE PHONE RECORDS
FROM, WHAT, PHONE COMPANY?
>> SPYING ON A MEMBER ON THE
PRESIDENT'S LAWYER, SERIOUSLY,
AND --
>> HE NEEDS TO TREAD VERY
CAREFULLY, RIGHT,
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGE.
WHAT HE'S DOING, AND THAT'S WHY
TODAY IN THE WHITE HOUSE, WE
WROTE A LETTER, PAT WROTE A
LETTER TO NADLER SAYING THAT
NANCY PELOSI HAS ALREADY
PREDETERMINED GUILT.
SHE'S ORDERED THEM TO GO AHEAD
WITH ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT SO
WHY IN THE WORLD WOULD WE
PARTICIPATE IN ANY OF THIS SHAM?
THEY NEED TO DROP IT NOW.
BUT IF THEY DON'T, WE WROTE IN
HOUR LETTER, YOU KNOW WHAT?
IF YOU DON'T DO IT FAST, GET IT
TO THE SENATE, WHERE WE CAN HAVE
A FAIR TRIAL BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WHO WE WANT TO CALL?
ADAM SCHIFF.
WE WANT TO CALL THE
WHISTLEBLOWER, AND WE WANT TO
CALL HUNTER BIDEN AND DON'T YOU
FINE IT INTERESTING, SEAN THAT
ADAM SCHIFF WON'T EVEN BE
PRESENTING HIS REPORT.
HE'S HAVING THE LAWYER, COUNSEL
DO IT INSTEAD OF HIM.
I WONDER WHY HE DOESN'T WANT TO
TESTIFY?
KEN STARR PRESENTED HIS REPORT
BUT ADAM SCHIFF SURE DOESN'T
WANT TO PRESENT HIS.
IF THIS GOES TO THE SENATE, IT
SHOULDN'T EVER GO THIS, WE WANT
TO HEAR FROM ADAM SCHIFF.
HANNITY: MATT GATES, THIS IS
VERY DISTURBING TO ME, THE
PRESIDENT'S LAWYER, A FELLOW
MEMBER OF CONGRESS AND A
REPORTER, AND THE PHONE COMPANY
HAS COOPERATED.
I HAVE A PROBLEM WITH ALL OF
THAT.
DO YOU THINK THERE IS A PROBLEM?
>> I DO.
SEAN, IT WAS JUST YESTERDAY,
THOUGH, THAT YOU AND I WERE
SPEAKING ABOUT OUR MUTUAL LOVE
FOR THE PEOPLE OF PENSACOLA.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT OUR
HEARTS ARE BREAKING NOW AS OUR
SERVICE MEMBERS ARE DEALING WITH
THIS TRAGIC ACT OF VIOLENCE THAT
OCCURRED IN MY COMMUNITY.
HANNITY: BY THE WAY, I SAW YOUR
TWEETS EARLIER TODAY, LET ME
ECHO YOUR COMMENTS.
I LOVE THE PEOPLE OF PENS CO-LA.
YOU KNOW HOW I FEEL.
>> THEY LAUGH
>> THEY LOVGH
>> THEY LOVE YOU, TOO.
WHEN I COMPARE THEM WITH THE
SAVAGY OF WASHINGTON, D.C. THE
CONTRAST COULD NOT BE MORE
STARK.
SCHIFF IS ONE OF THE LOWEST
SBEGTY PEOPLE THAT I HAVE SEEN
IN PUBLIC LIFE.
IF HE STANDS BEHIND THESE ALWAYS
ALLEGATIONS HE SHOULD AT LEAST
HAVE THE GUTS TO SHOW UP AND
DEFEND THEM HIMSELF BUT INSTEAD
HE'S SENDING HIS LAWYERS AND AS
FAST AS -- AND STAFF.
I THINK IT'S BECAUSE ADAM SCHIFF
KNOWS THAT AS A CONSEQUENCE OF
HIS LIES, AS A RESULT OF
CONDUCTING MOST OF THIS IN THE
BUNKER OF THE CAPITAL HE HAS NO
CREDIBILITY SO THE DEMOCRATS ARE
LOOKING FOR MAYBE A LAWYER OR
STAFFER WITH MORE CREDIBILITY
THAN SCHIFF.
WHEN IT COMES TO THESE PHONE
RECORDS, YOU'RE RIGHT.
THERE IS A TRAMPLING OF RIGHTS
THAT GOES FAR BEYOND THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY.
IT SPEAKS TO OUR SEPARATION OF
POWERS, OUR SIEVE LIBERTIES, AND
DEMOCRATS USED TO CLAIM THEY
WERE THE PARTY OF CIVIL